now that I know how you really feel
I'm going back to the house I'm packing
my suitcases I'm getting a hotel and
we're parting ways yes don't hesitate
Miss Debbie say it you are parting ways
breaking up splitting so call me a cab
[Music]
a devastated Debbie breaks up with Usama
after he admits his main agenda with her
is getting a green card so he can sell
his art in the states
I feel used right now
and guess what I deserve it
for believing in him
as Debbie confesses she's now scared of
Osama he keeps changing and it always
happens at night
I'm afraid of the dark here in Morocco
it's like he changes completely well she
can't say he didn't warn her I know that
there is a Madness inside of me let's
get into it
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
oh there is so much to talk about this
week oops wait I got lipstick on my
teeth all right back to it but before we
get into the biggest must-see moments
from Usama and Debbie Danielle and Johan
and Rishi and Jen I want to acknowledge
and send my love to those of you who are
in the middle of a transition in life a
transformational period that's been
tough I know we all have different
circumstances but know that you are not
alone I know it sounds cliche but when
you're going through it it really does
help to know that personally I've been
learning that life has an interesting
way of maturing us all and taking us to
the next level sometimes it can feel
like you're going backwards or even
losing your mind
I know the feeling but I always try to
remind myself that growth is not a
linear process a butterfly went through
a dark period to become as beautiful as
it is
so continue to choose to believe that
there is a wonderful future ahead
waiting for you over entertaining those
fearful and negative thoughts I know it
can be easier said than done but
that's the work
don't give up you have my love and
support as well as the support from the
kind-hearted souls in the community who
just continue to impress me I love how
we can talk about the messiness of this
show yet keep it wholesome at the same
time look at us
speaking of the mess the first must-see
moment from this week
[Music]
had me embarrassed for Johan and
Danielle
but let me give you a quick backstory to
catch up those who are not aware
Daniella's 42 from New York and she
moved to the Dominican Republic to be
with her 32 year old husband Johann now
Danielle came up with this idea for
Johan to meet her ex-boyfriend Taylin
who was in the Dr on vacation and she
doesn't just want them to meet she wants
them to become friends which in my
opinion is pushing it you can't force a
friendship between two grown men but
anyway all this has Johan confused and
bothered on top of not liking the idea
that she and her ex are still close
[Music]
he has no interest in becoming friends
with this man yet Danielle has been
pretty persistent about it if this thing
is going to piss Johan off this much he
is going to be miserable for the
majority of our relationship because I
have a lot of people in my life that
yawn's not going to be fond of clearly
well when it comes to her ex Talen they
were together for about four months in
2020. she basically called it a pandemic
fling nothing serious but she says it's
blossomed into a friendship that brings
value to her life
they all that being said Danielle
finally gets Johan to meet Halen
[Music]
oh okay Johan don't be a hater what's
going on guys how's it going how are you
nice to meet you now
once they sit down it's straight awkward
silence
and in my head I'm thinking talk
Danielle you wanted this
instead Johan takes the floor and starts
asking questions he's curious about like
how did Taylin and Danielle meet and how
long were they together then I don't
know if it was the drink he was sipping
or what but Johan starts to make moves
that honestly show his maturity level at
this point I understand it was an
uncomfortable situation for him but
sheesh okay come on
stand up first he wanted to see how tall
he was in comparison to Taylin and then
he asked the man what his shoe size is
for one reason alone
um
Grand
[Music]
whoa wait hey did I hear that he said
the interesting part about this moment
is that Danielle
knows the answer to that
and shout out to Taylor for being a good
sport Johan is really trying to see if
he is packing and just because it's big
doesn't mean it's great sweetie that's
the first myth and second are we in high
school I don't think shoe size always
determine size
oh
this is a lot in my opinion Johann is
way out of line but obviously his
comments and actions are coming from a
place of insecurity so a part of me
can't help but think oh get it together
Johan get it together
when you're on ask me how big my penis
was it was extremely strange
that's a question that women usually ask
so the fact that a married man asked me
that called me off guard but you know
it happens
you don't ask them in that question okay
problema it's an embarrassing question
to hear you ask that's the problem Johan
goes on to ask Taylin how was his sex
with Danielle no girl yes
[Music]
no
okay no why because y'all are married
Bro
did Johann forget does the fact that
he's a married man mean anything to him
dang most of the time when you come
across your ex and you're with your new
partner you want to you know sure you
got something good something slick
better but
I don't know about this situation
the combo ends with Taylin asking Johan
does he trust Danielle and Danielle
breaking down in tears because clearly
Johan doesn't well she wanted this meet
and greet bright side is that she's seen
a new side of her husband that she'll
have to decide if she can live with
all right super quick update on Rishi
and Jen so we can move on to Debbie and
Usama to rishi's surprise Jen's friends
direct The Interpreter to tell his mom
that he and Jen have been engaged for
three years this as rishi's family has
been attempting to find him a bride in
India I don't know what is going on it
was something like I'm dreaming
I just want to put those words back in
the Randy's mouth but I can't of course
rishi's mom is shocked she had no clue
he and Jen were even dating meanwhile
jyn has moved across the world to be
with him but that's another conversation
once Jen and her friends leave rishi's
family's home rishi's Uncle asked about
Jen's age
and his mom was even more shocked to
find out that he's engaged to someone 16
years older than him at this point she
flat out tells Rishi no he does not have
her blessing to marry jyn it's a
relationship she won't accept this
conversation gave me flashbacks to
submit talking to his parents about
Jenny so yeah now Rishi has to break the
news to Jen that his family does not
support them getting married after she
uprooted her life to be with him hmm all
right let's move on to the biggest
must-see moment of the week
Debbie and Usama parting ways ladies and
gentlemen and of course it wouldn't be
90 day if there wasn't a Twist at the
end but we'll get to that so your real
plan is just come get to the Visa get to
the United States and that's that's it
for you that's that's how it goes this
week's episode picks up on Usama telling
Debbie he wants her to take him to the
United States so he can work and get
paid for his art an intense back and
forth that started after Debbie asked
Usama to make solid plans for the life
that she thought they were building in
Morocco my plan is
I can make lots of money to make all
Studio Art because Dev art is valuable
so you will bring me to the U.S because
for me as a bunch of as Apple which
there is no future for me here
you will bring me to do sa and
you can guarantee my future there
it's all about your future all about
your future
say yeah like that wow and USANA was
talking about making lots of money in
the state's office art does he not know
that artists struggle in the U.S too I
get that the circumstances are much
better than Morocco but it's still not
easy and Debbie knows that that's
probably why she said this
I'm sorry
I love an artist and a poet but I'm not
supporting a man I'm not going to marry
someone that wants a Visa I'm not
marrying someone that just wants a Visa
and go to the United States so always
stop this
and move to the United States for him to
get a green card
when did that come up in our three years
of conversation
well Miss Debbie he's not going to tell
you that I'm using every last bit of my
self-control not to knock him into next
week it's like
you're scum of the earth Debbie goes on
to tell Usama how she feels about him no
you've done me dirty you're nasty you're
not honorable you're you're creepy man
you can tell she means that
I'm creepy I'm bad I'm ugly I'm I'm
still a okay is that God for you
yeah let's just go let's just get out of
here you know this is like it's no use
beating a dead horse let me say this
I think the majority of us can agree
that Debbie has no business being in
Morocco with 24 year old Usama
we know that I don't know if it was her
loneliness making her blind like Lacey
says or if it's trauma that caused her
to feel as if this relationship could be
something real or if she's living in a
fairy tale world I don't know but she's
there and I just want to say I'm glad
she's there with the production crew I'm
not trying to paint Usama as a dangerous
guy but just look at this shot right
here think about if they were alone I
would be terrified if I was in Debbie's
shoes she's a vulnerable woman and Osama
is not giving off safe and secure Vibes
right now at all you know it takes a lot
of courage to open your heart after
being closed for 12 years
I opened a little door
and a poem slipped through that door
and I was stupid to read it and I'll
never read another poem again from
another person
Mrs Debbie let's not be dramatic
she's just a little hurt right now
Debbie goes on to tell Usama she's
packing her things leaving his parents
house getting a hotel and she tells him
they are parting ways and to call her a
cab whatever you want I came here with
good intentions and a belief that
something like age didn't matter
I feel used right now
and guess what I deserve it
for believing in him oh well she said it
so you don't have to
personally I don't think one deserves to
get used like that but when you don't
listen to Red Flags who else can you
blame when something blows up in your
face
okay this is Debbie leaves Usama and is
giving off The Bachelor and she didn't
get a rose my inner child has been
slapped around he took my trust and he
just
urinated all over it Debbie in her
choice of words and there's Usama left
alone with a cat
he did say he prefers cats over people
just like he said he has Madness in him
does that ever concern you
um his darker side or the madness he
might have in him yes he is often
mentioned that he has some kind of
Madness and then he even tells me Debbie
you have holy Madness and it's like it
became kind of a catchphrase but I
understood him to be kind of like the
lone wolf in his community look moral of
the story believe somebody when they
tell you who they are and don't assume
you can heal them I wanted to Osama to
like Bloom as a person because he had
been downturner such as myself it's
beautiful to have the heart to help but
as they say a person has to want it more
for themselves then you want it for them
Julian Julian it's mama
no it's you Mom Debbie is so dramatic
fast forward she calls her son Julian to
tell him what's going down in Morocco
and I'm like yes tell him what's up so
he can put his superhero cape on and
come get you
[Music]
what happened
well he said made some very cruel
remarks that wasn't like the Osama I
know
he he keeps changing and it always
happens at night that's why she was
calling him creepy I'm afraid of the
dark here in Morocco it's like he
changes completely
sounds like he's more Dr Jekyll Mr Hyde
than Prince Charming all right well and
that's that's what I'm leading up to
Debbie tells Julian about Usama wanting
to use her to come to the states and get
a visa and although he's already warned
his mom he's pissed
you know I didn't see ever see it
happening like this I was looking for my
happily ever after and I don't have that
much Ever After
I need to make a compilation of Debbie
in her phrases
she says she doesn't have that much Ever
After
KK says Debbie is a whole vibe A vibe
she is a mood for sure now back to
Julian I'm assuming knowing his mama he
tells her okay we don't need to waste
any time you need to cut baptized with
them you need to
block him let's make a plan to get you
out of Morocco before Osama comes and
tries to roll you back in then
Debbie says this I'm mourning the loss
of my best friend
you know now it's like Debbie just stop
leave go home
but I don't know if I'm ready to do that
what Debbie is about to make me hang up
on her please hang up and try again
I miss my buddy you know
I miss my friend you know
I knew he was no good from the beginning
I say cut your losses kick him to the
curb and come home oh Debbie is falling
into the Trap that comes with ending a
toxic relationship yeah y'all grew super
close and he probably was your closest
friend but was he a good friend no
because if he was he wouldn't have said
those things to you or treated you that
way maybe she's afraid of being lonely
again I don't know but next week she
meets up with Usama face to face I told
you this before that's when I am angry
you don't have to care about what I'm
saying
I love dibib and I don't want to love
fighting that they're in the farm we
build lost tanks between me and you're
like a ticking Time Bomb I don't know if
next week you're gonna get angry again
but love can conquer anything
oh
hopefully she's not sacrificing her own
well-being still taking on the job to
try to heal him that is the wrong tree
to bark up
I sound like Debbie in her phrase is but
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all let's hope Miss Debbie makes a wise
decision I'll see you next time
foreign